Hi everyone,
so I'm making an announcement today and
I suppose you might regard it as an
advertisement so I'm warning you to
begin with because I don't want you to
waste your time if you're not interested
in listening to a description of the
newest thing that we've created.
So we just put up a website called
understand myself.com and it's a
personality assessment for individuals
and it's based on a personality model
that was developed in my lab about 10
years ago by Dr Colin De Young and a
Lien Dr Lena quilty.
Dr Young is now a professor at the
University of Minnesota and it was based
on some ideas that I had been developing
with another former student of mine,
Dr Daniel Higgins,
who's a partner with me in this
enterprise along with my former graduate
supervisor,
Dr Robert Peel from Mcgill University.
It's based on the big five personality
model which measures extroversion,
which is a positive emotion dimension on
is associated with gregariousness and
enthusiasm and assertiveness and
sociability and that sort of thing.
And,
uh,
a trait called neuroticism,
which is basically negative emotionality
which is associated with a proclivity
towards anxiety and emotional pain,
agreeableness,
which is compassion and politeness.
And so agreeable people are,
I would say,
broadly speaking,
rather maternal and their orientation,
they tend to care more for others than
for themselves.
They're more cooperative than
competitive,
whereas so-called disagreeable people
are more competitive and more Bruce Guy
would say,
and perhaps more straightforward and
more able to stand up for themselves as
well.
Conscientiousness is another one of the
dimensions that's orderliness and
industriousness.
And the last dimension is openness to
experience,
which is a combination of interest and
ideas which is often known as intellect
and a interest in aesthetics,
um,
and which is associated,
let's say with creativity.
And that's the dimension that's also
most highly correlated with Iq.
We developed the big five aspect scale
in an attempt to take the big five.
So that's extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness to
experience which are the canonical
dimensions of personality.
We developed the big five aspects scale
in order to break down those big five
traits,
each of them into their two most
statistically robust subcomponents and
we call those aspects and that's
actually become a pretty popular
personality model.
The scientific paper which announced
that a statistical division has accrued
about 750 citations,
which is an awful lot of citations by
the way,
for a scientific paper.
It makes it into a kind of classic,
um,
especially because it's only also only
had 10 years to accrue citations and
citation is when some other scientists a
refers to the paper in one of their
papers,
by the way.
Anyways.
I've been working over the last couple
of years to generate really detailed
personality reports on each of the big
five traits and the 10 aspects at about
seven different levels of specificity
ranging from extremely low to extremely
high.
And we think we've produced what might
be the most comprehensive and accurate
personality reports that are currently
available.
You answer 100 questions in order to
complete the personality survey.
The questions themselves are actually
public access,
or you could call them open source.
They were derived from Lou Goldberg's
Ip,
international personality item,
pool there the consequences of many,
many decades of attempts to define a set
of phrases that most comprehensively and
also most concisely captures the
variation in human personality and so
you can find those questions many places
on the line,
but the reports themselves and the
comparison sample of approximately
10,000 people are proprietary and
constitute the essential element of
value in in our offering.
Essentially what we're hoping is that
people can use this personality test
site to develop a much deeper
understanding of themselves so that they
know what their light,
especially compared to others and that
they can also compare themselves to
anyone else.
For example,
who might have taken the test and see.
The thing about personality is that the
differences between people actually run
quite deep.
There's a lot of individual variability,
so there are people who are extremely
extroverted and they want to spend every
moment of their time socializing with
other people and there are people who
are very introverted and they want to
work alone and they find interactions
with.
With large groups of people or even
small group,
sometimes quite tiring and they have to
spend a lot of time recovering.
They tend to be much more quiet,
not necessarily shy because that shyness
is more a consequence of variation on
the second dimension,
neuroticism and so people are high in
neuroticism.
Our field,
much more anxiety and emotional pain per
unit of uncertainty and stress than
people who are very low in neuroticism,
who are often known as emotionally
stable and who tend to be quite
imperturbability.
Agreeable people,
as I mentioned before,
are warm and compassionate and and very
much care for other people but are also
likely to be taken advantage of and to
feel a certain amount of resentment.
Whereas disagreeable people are tough
and straightforward and competitive and
out for victory,
but can also be somewhat self centered
and harsh and then conscientious.
People are hardworking and beautiful.
Conscientiousness is a really good
predictor of longterm life success,
especially in academic attainment where
it's second only to icu and also in
managerial and administrative jobs that
require attention to detail and a fair
bit of responsibility,
let's say,
and routine work,
openness to experience.
That's the creativity dimension and some
people are extremely high in openness to
experience and they want to do nothing
but discuss ideas and and spend their
time in creative and artistic pursuits
and other people are more conservative
because low openness is with
conservatism and they're not really
interested novel ideas and they don't
think abstractly that often and they're.
They're not out for new experiences or
flights of fantasy or imaginative
exercises or any of that thing.
There are a lot more concrete and
practical.
Now.
The reports that we've prepared not only
provide you with information about all
of the aforementioned big five traits,
they also break each one down into its
dual aspects.
So there's actually 15 different sources
of information that are contained in the
reports and so for extroversion,
you get a description of the degree to
which you are assertive,
which means forthcoming,
let's say,
in public and and willing to put your
opinions forward and enthusiasm,
which is a more pure marker of positive
emotion and the capacity to look forward
to and enjoy events and situations
spontaneously.
And with neuroticism.
You learn about the trait aspects,
withdrawal and volatility and withdrawal
is the tendency to be stymied or,
or stopped,
let's say,
by fear to be frozen in some sense like
a prey animal.
And volatility is an aspect that's
associated with irritability.
And the tendency to,
uh,
be easily rubbed the wrong way,
let's say.
And to react emotionally to that.
And then for agreeableness,
there's two aspects and one is
compassion,
which means pretty much what it says,
it's the ability to embody the feelings
of others and to react in a caring
manner to that and politeness,
which seems to be something like respect
for authority and social conventions.
And so one of the things you see,
for example,
is that liberals are higher in
compassion and conservatives are higher
and politeness,
even though they're both aspects of
trait.
Agreeableness conscientiousness breaks
down into two aspects as well,
which are quite interesting.
One of them is industriousness,
which is associated with diligent,
hard work and the ability to stay task
focused without distraction and to work
hard and orderliness,
which seems to be associated with
disgust sensitivity and which is a
pretty good predictor of conservative
belief.
Uh,
as it turns out that some elements of
conservative belief are associated with
higher than normal levels of or higher
than average,
let's say,
levels of disgust sensitivity.
And the final trait division into
aspects is that of openness to
experience.
And it can be divided into openness
proper,
which is essentially a dimension of
creativity and aesthetic sensitivity.
So preference for engagement in
activities that are associated,
say with fiction or drama or art and
intellect,
which is an index of interest in ideas
and abstraction and philosophical
concepts and that sort of thing.
So the report produces a very high
resolution representation of personality
and they're very interesting differences
at the aspect level that are worth
concentrating on.
We try to develop a personality test
that isn't designed to make you feel
good about yourself,
although it might know it depends on
your personality,
but to give you the most accurate and
straightforward description of who you
are that's possible so that you can use
the genuine information that's provided
in order to maybe organize your life.
Also understand the difference between
yourself and other people because you
know we often think that the reason that
we don't share the same viewpoint is
because we have differences of opinion,
but it actually goes a lot deeper than
that because you're very.
Perceptions are dependent on the
variability in your personality and so
it isn't only that people differ in
their opinions.
They differ very much in how they see
the world,
how they actually perceive the world.
Because your personality constitutes a
kind of template or filter through which
you organize your perceptions.
And so it's very important to understand
that there is substantial personality
variability in the world and that you're
often talking with people who see things
differently than you.
And a good example of that is the divide
between,
let's say left leaning people in,
right leading people because the left
leaning,
people tend to be very high in openness
to experience and relatively low in
conscientiousness,
especially in the aspect of orderliness.
Whereas the conservative types tend to
be very high in conscientiousness,
especially orderliness and relatively
low in openness.
And so those are fundamentally different
orientations in the world.
And you could say that the more
conservative types,
that more right wing types are much more
concerned with the preservation of
tradition and tend to believe that
things that have been done,
the tried and true manner in the past
are the most reliable.
Whereas the people who are on the left
who are more radical or more concerned
with the fact that the environment
shifts radically and rapidly and
unpredictably and so we have to be
willing to shift with it.
And so those are both valid viewpoints
because every element of lived
experience has an orderly element and a
chaotic element,
let's say,
and you have to be prepared for both.
And the purpose of straightforward
political dialogue between people of
different personality types is to help
determine on an ongoing basis how much
we should be relying on tradition and
how much we should be attempting to
transform ourselves.
And there is no permanent solution to
that problem because things stay the
same and change and they do that at
different rates at different times.
So dialogue is unbelievably important.
Which by the way is why I'm such an
advocate,
let's say for free speech because it's
the mechanism that keeps people up,
different types speaking instead of
fighting.
So it's really important.
So anyways,
the website is called understand
myself.com and you can go there and sign
up for the personality test.
It'll be delivered to you pretty much
immediately after you fill out the
questions.
They.
Each question is posed as a phrase,
I'm take you about 15 minutes to
complete the questions.
You can only do it once.
And the reason for that is that the
norms that we compare you against,
so that would be the self reports of the
10,000 other people against whom you're
compared.
They were only allowed to do at once.
And so we have to maintain stringent
control over that to maintain that
validity of the test.
And,
uh,
I would say don't do it when you're
hungry.
Don't do it when you're tired,
don't do it when you're feeling down or
in a bad mood about yourself or feeling
self critical and don't do it when
you're likely to be interrupted or
distracted.
You want to take it seriously and you
want to think about your answers.
Now you're supposed to answer as you are
typically not as you'd like to be.
Um,
and you know,
you don't want to be either too hard on
yourself or too good to yourself.
You want to be as accurate as possible
because then you'll benefit most from
the feedback.
And then the last thing I would say is
that we've,
some of you know about this already,
but we've also developed a set of
interventions called self authoring.
And that's available at [inaudible] dot
com and what self authoring can help you
do is reconfigure certain elements of
your behavior and perhaps over the long
run your personality.
So the cell phone suite helps you write
an autobiography and detail out the,
uh,
both positive and negative experiences
of your past so that you can capitalize
on the positive experiences and figure
out how to duplicate them and maybe put
the negative experiences to rest and we
feel that that's a good way to reduce
trait neuroticism over the long run.
And the evidence for that is that
writing programs of this sort tend to
improve people's mental health and
decrease their negative emotion so and,
and stabilize them.
So.
So if you take the personality test and
you're not happy,
for example,
with your scores on trait neuroticism,
you feel that you would benefit from
some additional emotional stability.
Then the past authoring program from the
self authoring suite might be something
worth considering.
And then with regards to the other
personality traits,
I'm the present authoring program at
[inaudible] dot com is also a
personality exercise of a sort.
But what it helps you do is center on
your virtues and your false using a big
five model again so that you can
identify what's good about your
personality and figuring out how to
capitalize that on that in the future
and so that you can identify where your
major weaknesses are and figure out how
to rectify those.
And so that's useful for general
personality work I would say.
And then the last one which we've done
the most research on is called future
authoring.
And the future authoring program helps
you think about your life and we think
about it as an adjunct to
conscientiousness perhaps over the long
run and also as an exercise that could
increase positive and decreased negative
emotion by by helping you establish your
goals and also stabilizing your view of
the world.
So in the future authoring program,
you're asked to consider your life along
about seven dimensions.
So friendship,
intimate relationships,
what you do outside of work with your
private life in terms of useful and
creative activity or enjoyable activity
or social activity.
What you're aiming for in your career,
how you're going to configure your self
education.
How you're going to take care of
yourself mentally and physically and how
are you going to handle your use of
drugs and alcohol because those are
pitfalls that people often encounter
that that tear them down and hurt them
badly,
and so you're asked to think about
yourself three to five years down the
road as if you were taking care of
yourself as if you were a valuable
person.
You know,
because you want to extend that courtesy
to yourself because you're as valuable
on average as anyone else and you should
treat yourself that way.
So anyways,
you're asked to design a future three to
five years down the road where your
experience along each of those
dimensions is optimized.
And then you're asked to write for 15
minutes about what your life could be
like three to five years down the road.
If you were taking care of yourself the
way you should and things were working
out properly.
So you could imagine that you're
developing a vision of the life that
you'd like to lead.
And then you're asked to reverse that
and to write for 15 minutes.
And think about this as well.
About what your life would be like if
you let your bad habits and your
character,
logical weaknesses,
take the upper hand and Auger you into
the ground so that you became,
you know,
a failure and bitter and resentful and
isolated and unhappy and,
and all of the terrible things that go
along with bad luck and,
and also a missed opportunities.
And let's call them ethical errors.
So and then you're asked to take your
positive vision for the future and
elaborate that out into a detailed plan
where you justify your,
your goals,
you,
you describe what those goals are.
You rank order them in importance.
You describe how you would be better and
your family would be better and your
society would be better if you stuck to
your goals.
You make a contract with yourself to
determine how it is that you were going
to approach those goals and stay on path
and and so forth.
And so these are quite extensive
exercises and we develop them,
you might say,
as an alternative to lengthy and
expensive psychotherapy and there's a
fair bit of research evidence suggesting
that writing exercises of this sort are
extremely effective ways of
reconfiguring the manner in which you
approach the world.
And so the research we've done,
for example,
in three different locations now and
with with several thousand college
students,
although this is not a program only
designed for college students,
has indicated that even if you do a
relatively poor job of let's say the
future authoring program and you're a
college student,
it increases the probability that you'll
stay in your program by about 25
percent,
which is a walloping improvement and
also has about the same effect on your
grade point average.
And so that seems to be particularly
true for people who are doing the worst.
So it's been really effective for
disenchanted ethnic minority males in
Holland,
for example,
compared to the Dutch national females
who do better than anyone else in the
sample that we looked at two years after
the entire group did the future
authoring program.
The ethnic minority males who are
underperforming by about 80 percent
caught up and slightly exceeded the
performance of the Dutch national women.
So that was absolutely staggering
results as far as we're concerned.
We also duplicated that at a place in
Canada called Mohawk College,
showing that the program worked
particularly effectively for men again,
for males who are underperforming
females generally speaking in the
academic world and especially if they
were males who hadn't done that well in
high school and hadn't carved out a very
specified a route forward in their
academic achievement.
So it's an excellent way of getting your
act together.
And so anyways,
the understand myself.com page is
designed to give you a picture of your
personality in detail and then the self
authoring program is designed to help
you reconfigure the way that you
approach life.
And so we're hoping that the combination
of those two things are particularly
effective way of bringing high quality
psychological information and advice and
help to a very broad audience at a very
low cost and at a relative minimum of
demands on time.
Um,
I would say we do know with the self
authoring program that the more you
write,
the better it works,
which is sort of tantamount to saying
that the program works better in your
life,
gets better,
the more you think about the future,
which really stands to reason,
but it's nice to see that actually
represented and duplicated as part of a
scientific research project.
So anyways,
we've tried to keep the programs as
reliable as possible,
as straightforward as possible,
as dependent on your own actions as
possible because the writing is really
crucial to reconfiguring your
personality and as widely distributable
and as low cost as we can possibly
manage.
We're trying to provide you with
accurate psychological information so
that you understand yourself and other
people better and so that your life can
be configured in a manner that I hope is
much more beneficial to you personally,
personally and helpful to your family
and also has a positive effect on the
broader society around you.
Because that's a great triumvirate of
attainment and it's exactly what you
should be aiming for.
So I would say I encourage you to
determine who you are and to think about
that very carefully and then to
determine very carefully who you want to
be and why and to make a plan.
You know you don't get the opportunity
to do that in school,
junior high,
high school,
College,
university,
no one ever sits you down and helps you
figure out where you came from and who
you are and what you're doing and you
really need to know that.
I should also say that with the
understand myself dotcom site,
we're also working on our couples module
that will enable the people who have
filled out the report to ask someone
else to also do the questionnaire and
then they'll both get a report that
details out there similarities and
differences so that they can come to
understand where they're going to be an
agreement and get along and share
interests and where they're likely to
have conflict and what might be done
about that.
And I would say that's at minimum a
month to two months away.
And we're also going to release a high
school version of the self authoring
suite.
So that people can start to plan their
lives when they're much younger and will
only ask the high school students to
think about three to months out into the
future because when you're that young,
that's about the practical limit of
your,
I wouldn't say ability to think forward
into the future,
but the younger you are,
the shorter your time horizon,
partly because,
well,
you haven't been exposed to the world
that much and there's,
you still have plenty to learn.
So,
but anyways,
we have a high school version in the
works and so all announced that when it
comes out.
And so we all hope that you find these
offerings,
uh,
useful and practical and uh,
um,
and that they help you put your life
together so that you can be a solid
citizen and a responsible person and as
emotionally stable as possible and maybe
even find some happiness along the way
from time to time.
So that would be really good.